we also updated our forward guidance  indicating that an increase in the  target range for the federal funds rate  remains unlikely at our next meeting in  April with continued improvement in  economic conditions however we do not  want to rule out the possibility that an  increase in the target range could be  warranted at subsequent meetings let me  emphasize however that the timing of the  initial increase in the target range  will depend on the committee's  assessment of incoming information  today's modification of our guidance  should not be interpreted to mean that  we have decided on the timing of that  increase in other words just because we  remove the word patient from the  statement doesn't mean we're going to be  impatient moreover even after the  initial increase in the target funds  rate our policy is likely to remain  highly accommodative to support  continued progress toward our objectives  of maximum employment and two percent  inflation